Vladimir Putin es nuestro Chuck Norris
particular. En VisualPolitik le hemos
dedicado decenas de vídeos y vosotros,
nuestros queridos susscriptores siempre
nos pedís más. Así que hoy vamos a
hablar del videojuego favorito de Putin
Ucrania es como el Paris Hilton de
los países, sólo hablamos de ellos
cuando ha ocurrido algo realmente malo y
lo cierto es que en este país llevan
tres años sin tener una buena noticia.
Durante el año 2016 parecía que estos
dos bandos que se han visto enfrentados
en una encarnizada guerra, el prorruso y
el pro-ucraniano iban a llegar a un
acuerdo. Sin embargo en febrero de 2017
ha ocurrido algo que ha vuelto a colocar
a Ucrania en el punto de mira de la
noticia: Rusia acepta los pasaportes
emitidos por los rebeldes ucranianos.
Ojo porque esto es muy importante. Hasta
ahora
Vladimir Purtin negaba en público
estár apoyando al bando pro ruso.
De hecho, la comunicación oficial del
kremlin
siempre se ha referido a estos grupos
como los separatistas rebeldes.
Por supuesto que todas las evidencias
apuntaban a que Putín estaba ayudando
con armamento y apoyo militar a las
facciones rebeldes,
de la misma forma que la OTAN estaba
haciendo lo mismo con el ejército
ucraniano.
Pero la versión oficial del gobierno
ruso es que ellos no tenían nada que
ver con el tema.
Sin embargo esta noticia marca un antes
y un después. A partir de ahora
Rusia reconoce de facto como estados
soberanos a las repúblicas populares
del Donetsk y Lugansk.  Y os preguntaréis
¿y todo esto qué consecuencias tiene?
Pues varias: por un lado se están
posicionando clara e institucionalmente
por uno de los bandos del conflicto.
Pero por el otro lado, Putin está
reconociendo que estas dos repúblicas
no son parte de Rusia. Es decir, hasta
ahora todos pensábamos que Putín
quería invadir Ucrania y anexionarlo
como una parte más de Rusia, pero ¿de
verdad esto es así?
Hoy vamos a responder esta pregunta y lo
vamos a hacer de la mano del que fue
corresponsal de guerra en Ucrania para
Televisa y la televisión checa, Carlos
González. No sólo eso, además Carlos
es uno de los pocos periodistas que ha llegado
a estar capturando por un escuadrón
del ejército pro ruso.
Y de hecho,  todas esas imágenes nunca vistas
hasta ahora van a salir a la luz en un
documental titulado "Ucranía la guerra
olvidada".  - Hola Fonseca, y un abrazo a
todos los suscriptores de VisualPolitik.
Efectivamente como dice ese Putín tiene
intereses por Ucrania. Aunque resulta un
poco aventurado pensar en este momento
que quieran anexarse el país o parte
de él. Hay varias razones para pensar esto, pero
en primer lugar yo pienso que Putín jamás
tuvo intereses serios de anexarse digamos la zona de
Lugansk o alguna otra zona
rusoparlante en Ucrania. Si no porque ¿habría enviado
tremendas cantidades de armamento
ayuda  logística, municiones, a un país que
finalmente terminaría tan dañado?
Pero esperad un momento porque antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia.
A diferencia de otras repúblicas
exsoviéticas como Bielorrusia donde la
mayor parte de la población se siente
muy cercana a Rusia, la historia de
Ucrania es muy distinta y la podemos
resumir como una tensión entre dos
partes muy diferenciadas. En este mapa
electoral
podéis ver esta franja azul en la parte
oeste del país.
Estos son los ucranoparlantes  que
mayoritariamente votan a partidos
políticos más o menos liberales y pro
europeístas.
Sin embargo, la otra mitad como podéis
ver, es completamente roja. En estas
áreas es donde se vota mayoritariamente
al Partido de las Regiones, que es el partido
político en el que se afiliaron todos
los antiguos gerifaltes del Partido
Comunista Soviético. Entre ellos este
señor que veis aquí que se llama
Víctor Yanukovich. Quedaros con ese
nombre porque es uno de los
protagonistas de esta historia.
Durante los años 90 está élites
post-soviéticas tenían el poder.
Sin embargo, en el año 2003 las tornas
se cambiaron:
hablamos de la llamada Revolución
Naranja donde todos los sectores pro
occidentales encabezados por Yulia
Timoshenko y Víctor Yúschenko se
hicieron con el gobierno
- Sin embargo este nuevo  gobierno no supuso ningún
cambio sustancial para el país.
No se aplicaran reformas importantes,
es más, ni siquiera fueron capaces de
desmantelar la policía política
represiva de Yanukovich. Como resultado
en el año 2010 el Partido de las Regiones
se convirtió en la principal fuerza
política, volvieron a ganar las
elecciones y el propio Yanukóvich se
convirtió en 2010 en el presidente del
país. Y por supuesto una de sus primeras
medidas fue meter en la cárcel a Yulia
Timoshenko. En este segundo gobierno de
Yanukóvich los ucranianos, sobre todo
aquellos que no le votaron, sufrieron en sus
propias carnes la corrupción, la
desigualdad económica y la brutalidad
policial.
Sin embargo, en noviembre de 2013
estalló una nueva revolución y esta
sí que estaba llamada a cambiar la
historia de Ucrania para siempre. El
gobierno de Yanukovich que estaba a punto
de firmar un tratado de asociación con la
Unión Europea, algo que era apoyado por
muchos ucranianos, principalmente
en occidente, donde son más
pro-europeos, y además, se habían forjado
muchas esperanzas porque se trataba de
colocar a Ucrania un pasito más cerca
de las estructuras euroatlánticas, es
decir, formar parte de la OTAN y formar
parte de la Unión Europea.
Sin embargo, en el último momento
Yanukóvich cedió a las presiones de
Putín y se negó a firmarlo. Así es
cómo surgieron las famosas protesta del
euro maidán.
Soy ucraniana, de Kiev,  y ahora estoy en
Maidán en el centro de mi ciudad.
Quiero que sepáis por qué miles de
personas de todo el país están en las
calles".
Más de 100 personas murieron en los
enfrentamientos que hubo entre la
policía y los manifestantes en unas
protestas que se alargaron durante meses.
Así que, al final, a Viktor Yanúkovich
no le quedó otra alternativa que esta:
"Me vi obligado a dejar Ucrania
bajo una amenaza a mi vida y a la vida
de mi familia". Y así es como Ucrania
comenzó una segunda transición
esta vez sin la influencia de las
élites herederas de la Unión
Soviética.
Y el mayor símbolo de esta nueva
revolución ucraniana fue la liberación
de Yulia Timoshenko.
Pero no sólo eso, muchos de estos grupos
que lograron deponer a víctor
yanukóvich se llegarán a plantear
prohibir el ruso en todo el país.
Pero pronto, esta otra Ucrania, de mayoría
rusoparlante, esa importante mayoría que
todavía incluso apoya de cierta manera
casi nostálgica a las antiguas élites.
Por eso, como sucedió en Crimea, en algunas regiones
del país, como el Donbass no estaban muy
de acuerdo con lo que estaba sucediendo
en Kiev.
Tampoco estaban de acuerdo con que se llevará a cabo una
transición. Según numerosos censos, casi
el 80% de la población de Crimea se
declararon rusoparlante y no sienten una
gran pertenencia a Ucrania. Por eso
cuando se empiezan a producir los
movimientos separatistas en Ucrania,
por allá por 2014,
entonces Crimea es uno de los primeros
en llamar a un referéndum de
autodeterminación.
A muchos os sonará porque solía ser una
zona de vacaciones. De hecho, era una
especie de Ibiza ucraniana. Muchos
europeos volaban hasta Simferópol para
pasar un fin de semana de fiesta.
No olvidéis que Crimea está en el mar
negro.
Se trata de una zona muy importante
desde el punto de vista militar y que
además tiene yacimientos de petróleo.
Es decir todas aquellas cosas que hacen
que un lugar sea atractivo para la
invasión. Así que desde el primer momento
vladimir putin se colocó en el lado de
los separatistas y antes de que el
ejército de ucrania pudiera hacer nada
ya estaban las tropas rusa ocupando el
lugar, mucho mejor equipadas, con muchos
más soldados y sobre todo con mucho
más apoyo de la población local. Así
que, ni siquiera hizo falta una guerra.
Los rusos llegaron dijeron esto es mío
y punto final.
Sin embargo, no ocurrió lo mismo en
estas otras dos zonas que veis en el
mapa: Donetsk y Lugansk. Esas regiones forman
parte de lo que se conoce como el
Donbass que es la zona más prorrusa de toda
Ucrania. Sin embargo, no tienen ningún
recurso natural ni ningún interés
estratégico de ningún tipo.
"Declaro la creación del estado
independiente y soberano de la
república popular de Donetsk".
Y así fue, con la declaración de
independencia de las repúblicas
populares de Donetsk y Lugansk como
empezó:
En ningún momento Rusia apoyó
oficialmente la independencia de ambas
regiones y esto ¿qué significa? os
preguntaréis. Pues que aunque les
mandaran asesoramiento militar, armamento
y material de todo tipo, no les mandaron
tropas a diferencia de lo que hicieron
en Crimea y esto sirvió para que el
ejército ucraniano se atreviera a hacer
frente a los separatistas.
Una de las batallas más importantes
diría yo de toda la guerra en Ucrania,
una de las batallas casi épicas fue
la batalla por el aeropuerto de Donetsk
Cubriendo la zona que va de Donetsk  al aeropuerto, zona según nosotros civil, fuimos
capturados por un batallón de milicianos
prorrusos, acusados de estar espiando
para una potencia occidental. Allá que
nos encontramos según ellos en zona de combate.
El momento en el que nos capturan nosotros decidimos
dejar la camina prendida para poder
tratar de grabar parte digamos
de ese momento tan dramático. La dejamos
prendida  incluso durante el período en
que somos trasladados al cuartel
general de las milicias rebeldes y parte
del interrogatorio que se desarrolla
después en medio obviamente de milicianos
armados hasta los dientes.
Nos venían acusando de estar trabajando
digamos de forma ilegal y de haber
estado espiando para intereses
extranjeros.
No olvidéis que
la OTAN también estaba apoyando al otro
bando, especialmente el gobierno de
Canadá que ha estado mandando a soldados,
asesores militares y armamento de todo
tipo. "Milicias rebeldes de la
autoproclamada República Popular de
Donetsk acusan a Kiev de ser
bombardeadas sus posiciones por
artillería pesada.
Y esto es una muestra de lo que estamos hablando
en estos momentos. Estos son esquirlas
de misiles de artillería pesada.
Estamos ya en febrero de 2015,
la situación es de auténtica guerra
civil con más de 5.000 muertos en ambos
lados del conflicto. Tanto Donetsk como
Lugansk son auténticos campos de batalla
y por supuesto el gobierno de Ucrania no
tiene ningún poder en estas zonas
controladas por los rebeldes.
Eso significa que ni las escuelas, ni los
hospitales, ni ningún edificio
administrativo puede funcionar
correctamente. Y lo más importante, los
ciudadanos comunes tienen que sobrevivir
en casas destartaladas y derruidas por
las bombas.
En ese momento es cuando representantes,
por un lado del gobierno de ucrania y
por otro lado de los supuestos gobiernos
de estas repúblicas recientemente declaradas,
se reúnen en Minsk para acordar
un alto el fuego.
Sin embargo, el cese al fuego jamás se
ha respetado: la violencia continua no
solamente entre los bandos beligerantes
sino también las violaciones contra la
población civil son cada vez más
evidentes.
Recuerdo haber estado caminando
por una aldea que fuera probablemente una
de las más castigadas durante la guerra,
a unos 800
kilómetros de Kiev, la capital de
Ucrania, cuando en la calle, en el
colegio público,  en el interior del colegio
público local nos encontramos una mina
antipersona sin estallar.
"Y esto señores es algo brutal, se trata de la
cabeza de una minas. No lo voy a hacer
porque esta mina todavía está
funcionando, lo que sucede cuando
aprieta este botón es que activa el
mecanismo que hace detonar la mina.
Si yo lo colocó arriba y aprieto el
botón en este momento, podría
efectivamente explotar". Horas después
escuchamos dos explosiones de minas
similares a ésta, se estima que cerca de
mil personas han perdido la vida por
explosiones de minas similares
a esta en Ucrania.
A día de hoy en el este de Ucrania es un lugar
sin gobierno.
Tanto Lugansk como Donetsk son zonas
controladas por señores de la guerra que
luchan entre ellos con la misma fiereza
con la que luchan contra el ejército de
Ucrania. Y en contra de lo que podríamos
pensar no hay ningún líder claramente
apoyado por Vladimir Putin.
Hay ciudades del Donbass
que han sido
literalmente arrasadas por la Guerra. Más
de un millón de personas se estima que
han tenido que escapar a otras partes
del país.
Las universidades se han visto forzadas a
cerrar sus puertas.
Es decir, si Rusia realmente quisiera anexarse
estos territorios tendría que desembolsar
importantes cantidades presupuestos para
poder reconstruir la infraestructura,
reconstruir carreteras, hospitales
La economía rusa en este momento no pasa
precisamente por su mejor momento.
Las sanciones impuestas por EEUU y la
Unión Europea a Rusia a raíz de Crimea
han tenido un impacto bastante
notorio en las finanzas del país. Y
pareciera que Putin no quiere volver a
repetir esto mismo,
más aún tratándose de territorios que
ofrecen una perspectiva geopolítica
tan, pero tan difusa.
No sólo eso, muchos pensareis que
Vladimir Putin
de alguna forma está apoyando a los
líderes pro rusos ¿verdad? Pues os
equivocáis.
Un señor de la guerra separatista Arseny Motorola Pavlov
muere en Donetsk.
Muchos piensan que este asesinato
podría ser una muestra de la guerra
territorial entre diferentes facciones
rebeldes en el este de Ucrania;
posiblemente incluyendo a algún
gerifalte de Moscú.
Y ahora os preguntaréis, si Putin no
quiere invadir Ucrania ¿qué intereses
tiene en este conflicto? Es decir, ¿qué
espera obtener de esta guerra? Todo esto
se explica con la famosa teoría de las
siete fases que define la política
exterior del kremlin. Si queréis entender
bien en qué consiste este principio
hacer clic en éste vídeo.
Y ahora la pregunta es ¿Creéis que Ucrania
debería separarse en dos países
distintos, uno pro-europeo y otro
prorruso? Podéis dejarme la respuesta en
los comentarios.
Pero esperad un momento porque tengo
algo importante que contaros. Si queréis
ayudar a difundir lo que está
ocurriendo en Ucrania
ahora tenéis una oportunidad. Este
documental del que hoy os hemos puesto
algunas piezas
esta apunto de proyectarse en los
principales festivales del mundo.
Pero antes falta un pequeño empujón en
la producción.
Mi amigo Carlos está buscando apoyo a
través de una plataforma de crowdfunding
que se llama indiegogo.
Así es Fonseca, gracias a decenas de
personas que han creído en esta
iniciativa es que hemos alcanzado dos
terceras partes de los fondos necesarios
para poder realizar este proyecto, pero
ahora necesitamos darle un empujoncito
más y es ahí donde tu audiencia nos
puede apoyar tremendamente. Amigos
de VisualPolitik
por favor si pueden apóyenos, aunque sea un
dólar, un modesto dolar puede marcar una
gran diferencia para poder ayudarnos
a alcanzar esta meta y si no por lo
menos danos like en nuestra página de
Facebook, comparte nuestra iniciativa en
las redes sociales, eso también nos
ayudará tremendamente. Podéis encontrar
todos los links en la descripción y de
verdad que es un proyecto que merece la
pena.
Carlos es amigo mío desde hace años
antes vivían Praga y es uno de los
pocos periodistas que ha estado a ambos lados
del conflicto ucraniano. Y os puedo
asegurar que muchas de las imágenes que
se van a ver en este documental son
únicas y no se han visto nunca antes.
Así que, si queréis apoyar a nuevos
creadores esta es una oportunidad muy
buena y como siempre
recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribíos
al canal para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo darle a like y nos vemos en
el próximo.
un abrazo y hasta pronto.